[Music]
hello and welcome to this video which is
about b6 based setup so after our one d4
black plays b6 on one of the first moves
often times called Queen's Indian in
fact I think and what we usually call
Queen's Indian is this opening a 6-3 b6
but of course we are delaying the move
c4 in favor of an early g3 and yeah we
are will often transpose into this
opening because we play C for later but
our move autumn has some interesting
twists and I think some twists that
probably will catch like players
unawares however in this chapter we are
also talking about setups where b6 is
combined not with a 6 and 9 f6 but
rather even with the g6 or even black
playing b6 on moves 1 and we should
start right there black could play b6 on
move 1 here
there is nothing particularly bad about
playing Knight f3 and g3 as we usually
do but I think that we should take this
opportunity to play for him this is good
for white when you get a big center and
with v6 like it's not really well
equipped to put up any decent counter
play against it so I think this is good
for white and it should be played I have
to admit that this is a relatively easy
part of this d4 abattoir because I have
looked at the same thing from the keep
it simple Evo repertoire and there is
absolutely no reason to change anything
from there so I'm basically recommending
the same thing that I already have from
the e4 b6 move water so if you have
looked at keep it simple for before this
is just going to be a repetition for you
ok is now black is going to play Bishop
to b7 you can also play a 6 and then it
could transpose like if he goes a 6 and
we and get something like that we have a
transposition to what we look at in a
minute or by the way black could also go
six Knight f3 b6 after which you form
also will transpose now b6 we're going
to go before we should be seven now
important point already here I think we
should absolutely play the move Bishop
d3 I think this is better better is a
strong word but I really do think it is
a bit more precise than playing the
Knight to c3 or 92 d2 even the reason is
that in some setups we want to be
flexible with the C pawn and the bishop
is good on d3 in any case so let's play
this first now him black usually plays
the move east six or the move Knight f6
the thing I think make the most sense
but we have to look at a move that
actually does not work but could could
be played against you if somebody is
really in a gambling mood or in a blitz
game that is to move f5 yeah black is
trying to use the long diagonal here and
the text the pawn on e4 the thing is
this is absolutely non-working but you
have to know why exactly and this is not
so um yeah it's not so obvious okay so
what are we going to do we take this
pawn and allow him to take on g2 because
we get this big check on h5 this black
hole can only answer with g6 of course
after which we take now the important
point is we are already threatening of
course made in one yeah with taking or
g7 and black choice is very very limited
there's a famous way to get checkmated
here for black the snide f6 after which
we check and you've made on g6 very cute
now black actually only has one move -
not yet immediately loose drastically
this is Bishop to g7 I mean he will lose
but not like in two moves Bishop g7 now
this is an important point we take King
edge King to evade only move and now
here this is the important point that I
wanted to mention here white is winning
with more than one continuation but you
absolutely have to play one of those if
you don't you are in trouble for example
it is not a good idea to now take on g8
I think the simplest way to win is the
move Knight to f3 let's look at this
yeah this is all extremely concrete move
by move based play we don't worry that
the rook is hanging we have to check
what happens if he takes the rook of
course now what happens takes and we
have the strong move Knight to e5 which
is threatening a simple made in one and
here black actually has no defense
anymore he has to cover that square
winter yet we take the rook has to take
now Queen to a5 Bishop f6 the only move
and another check and this is already
cashing in
and winning at least the Queen for the
moment this is very important black
cannot take the rook because of 1985 now
the move that actually looks more
worrisome after 93 is I have a different
one
is this one black develops with the
tempo and this is probably the move that
if you try to work this out over the
board that would irritate you a lot if
you think about 90 or 3 you might see
that taking that e5 is great but what
about this okay we go here and this is
the big point now the point is that
black now has no really good reply him
if he takes the rook we have the strong
move Bishop to h6
and the point now is after rube chicks I
mean it doesn't really have much else
rube cakes we have 95 and this is
completely killing we are threatening to
take here and of course first and
foremost made in one and there's no way
would black out of this
after queen g6 of course we attack the
bishop so it's all relatively forced but
I cannot just play any move we have to
check the other caption takes him and
here we have Roop she won Burton in
Queen g7 the rook has to take and now 23
and this is the sequence that is so
difficult to find over the book now if
you really want to ya develop this over
the wall you have to see many things
that twin g6 is coming the rook g1 and
now Queen g3 and this is a double attack
attacking the rook with disastrous
consequences and if the rook is taken
then g7 is falling immediately and of
course we attack and the bishop
now Bishop reform is relatively best we
take it
and give the check and now we see the
big point this is the TechEd
and what is black now supposed to play a
Sioux go here and then we win the
exchange on a 8 this is really a long
line and it's not as I said easy to find
over the board so it really makes sense
to look at them variations and gas to be
ready to just bang this on the board
once it happens it's just a point you
just win the game outright okay that was
f5 a bad move but it's worth having seen
the lines normally black is not so crazy
to play a 5 I mean they basically risk
to lose immediately they usually play
Knight f6 or e6 and they often actually
transpositional if we start with 9 f6 I
recommend to play Queen e2 don't ya yet
committed to a knight placement it's
often useful to use the C pawn this is
something that we see merely after nine
c6 which is a bit odd looking but it's
it's played like has tried this we have
the convenient move c3 now e5 Knight to
f3 and blackest of course threatened
here only 5 and you probably will play
d6 and now after castles I think White
has a comfortable position quite often
and white will continue with d5 and c4
and that looks a little bit like an old
Indian or like an e5 based set up with a
bishop is weirdly placed on b7 and the
other way for white to play is to keep
the tension play move like rook e1 or d1
and then get this night tour going which
looks a little bit like a rule or PES in
any case White has a central advantage
and it's a very sound classical way to
claim and if black goes with a six I
also recommend to develop the knight to
f3
that is the best 9 placement but don't
yet commit the c1 we will see now why I
am insisting on that um and it is if
black plays something like g6 the
hippopotamus as it had called in the
hippo black is trying to play a seventh
ring Center Bishop here 97 in hippo we
want to have a really broad center and
that means after castles Bishop g7 usual
place he for that is yet another
advantage of have not of having not
committed to the night early on and it's
not a mistake to play nights 3 but this
is better because we want this broad
center against a passive position that
black is setting up for example what I'm
getting at is something like this let's
play all those natural moves
[Music]
you